>> MATT JONES: Sure. I’m Matt Jones. I’m
vice president of Mobile Strategy and Operations
for Gannett.
>> STEPHEN TALLENT: I’m Stephen Tallent.
I’m President and CTO of Mercury Intermedia.
>> So how did you two come to work together?
>> MATT JONES: Well, we started working together,
I guess, last summer, and we hired Mercury
Intermedia to develop a native application
for iPhone for us that we launched in December.
And it’s been enormously successful; we’ve
been very, very pleased. And the next logical
extension for us, I think, was to move to
the Android platform.
>> So this is for USA Today?
>> MATT JONES: For USA Today, yes.
>> So describe the application a bit so I
would understand what it does.
>> MATT JONES: Stephen?
>> STEPHEN TALLENT: The application is intended
to be a very good user experience representing
content that USA Today has, not only headlines
but also scores and weather, and lots of different
types of photography, and even some interactive
polls; snapshots where users can vote on a
variety of different currents--current-issue
type things, and then see the answers to those
polls broken down by state and city or county,
that type of thing. To kind of see how people
in their area are responding to the same question.
>> So you’re already supporting something
like this on iPhone. What made you want to
support Android platforms as well?
>> MATT JONES: I think there are a lot of
really important strategic considerations
that went into deciding to build for Android.
Personally, I think, Android holds a lot of
promise as a development platform for Mobile.
I think we’re going to see a lot of growth
in the next, let’s say, six to 12 months
in terms of adoption both by end-users, by
carriers, you know, both here and North America
and also globally. And, I think it was an
important platform for USA Today to, you know,
continue to innovate, continue to be a leader
in this industry; that was an important platform
for us to support.
>> So, as a developer when you’re building
the application, what kinds of features in
Android did you find in those [INDISTINCT]?
>> STEPHEN TALLENT: Already having the app
developed on the iPhone made this more of
a porting process. So we already knew the
features set. We already know how it needed
to work. I could really focus on how quickly
can we get it to this new platform and get
it out to the market. So, I was really interested
in productivity from my development team and
getting it up to speed using XML for the layout
and a lot of the layout classes like the linear
layout and the relative layout. It really
sped us up as far as getting a faithful reproduction
of the app on a new platform really quickly.
It kept us really moving along and could move
to more testing as quickly as possible.
>> So in terms of meeting your clients’
needs for USA Today, how is Android for that?
>> STEPHEN TALLENT: It worked out really well,
in fact, better than the original product
because USA Today has such a recognizable
visual to their brand, to the colors, the
boldness that needed to translate as [INDISTINCT]
as possible. So, finding appropriate styles
and themes that we can apply to buttons or
to lists or to check boxes that match to say
to the brand was really important to us. And,
the way that Android allows the developers
to do the styles and themes made it really
quick and productive for us to then match
that brand which, of course, users instantly
recognize us, “Ah, this is USA Today Application,
it feels like USA Today” even though it’s
a very different form than the printed paper
they’re used to.
>> That’s terrific. So how was, how was
iOpen for you? Have you learned anything in
the conference? Is there anything that particularly
still stay when you go back?
>> MATT JONES: iOpen has been really an interesting
experience for me. I don’t go to a lot of
developer conferences. I’m not a, you know,
a developer or a programmer. So, you know,
a lot of it is a little bit lost on me but,
you know, I pick up probably the key components
to it and, you know, I think it’s just been
really interesting for me to be inversed--to
be immersed in such an interesting development
environment with, you know, some of the things
that we see Google rolling out like the announcement
today around Wave. You know, I think, it’s
just really exciting. There’s a tremendous
amount of innovation going on, on the Internet.